I just don't understand salespeople it's
it's you know it's actually a really
interesting trait that allows somebody
to be a good salesperson it comes down
to empathy are you able to put yourself
in the other person's hues I know what I
want I know how I want it to be but the
reason bader media has been successful
is because I haven't been stubborn about
forcing all of my clients who are nine
billion dollar companies to do it my way
I'm a little stumble
I'm a speedboat you know me as a brand a
person is a human I'm too teeny-tiny
vaynermedia small 100 million small 100
million small like my Pepsi client you
know they break that much product in a
month small not really but you know
small and so and so you need to be
empathetic I know how you want it to be
I know when you're hitting me up for 15
minutes of your my time what you want
out of it what do I want out of it what
do I get out of it and that's what I do
24/7 365
I check my wants at the door when I go
in sales mode and that's the flip
reverse of how most of you roll and
that's why I win the combination of
running the marathon I don't need it
right now I'm patient as [ __ ] and I
really give a [ __ ] about what you want
it's why you like me it's why this
content works it's why all these things
work because I think about you I don't
think about myself and so we need to
deploy empathy you think you're good
salesman
show me by deploying massive empathy and
awareness to the other person they're
not stupid they don't not get it they
don't get it the way you want it cuz
usually it's for you none of you trying
to sell me right now in the comments on
insta I know what you want but you're
trying to sell it to somebody you need
to understand what they want
that just came out of straight living
knowing what I just did the last 12
hours and going in these comment
sections and people just just not
deploying empathy if you want something
you need to reverse engineer the other
person
[Music]